>>> HAPPY THURSDAY!
ROUND ONE OF THE PLAYOFFS ARE
HEATING UP.
OEO
TOE WITH SIR CHARLES.
LAST WEEK, CHARLES BARKLEY AND I
BET ON JAYSON TATUM TO OUTSCORE
BRADLEY BEAL.
AMERICA TOOK BRADLEY BEAL.
AMERICA INCLUDES ERIN AND GREG.
>> TATUM JUST PUT UP A 50 PIECE.
A 50 PIECE TO BRADLEY BEAL'S 27.
>> WHAT A GAME.
>> CHUCK -- MORE IMPORTANTLY,
CHUCK GAINED ONE ON US IN THE
STANDINGS IN CHUCK VERSUS
AMERICA.
>> REALLY?
>> YEAH.
WE'RE 11-6, CHARLES BARKLEY IS
10-7.
SO THE RACE HAS TIGHTENED.
ALL THAT MATTERS IS THAT WE'RE
CLINGING TO THIS LEAD.
GREG IS STILL CLINGING TO HIS
HANDY DANDY iPAD.
>> I'M NOT LETTING THIS THING
GO.
ME AND THE iPAD, WE'RE TOGETHER.
>> YOU CANNOT DO THAT.
>> I KNOW, CABBIE.
WE GOT OFF TO A BIG LEAD.
I THOUGHT WE WERE RUNNING AWAY.
LIKE WHAT ARE WE DOING, AMERICA?
COME ON.
LET'S GET IN LINE.
LET'S TIGHTEN UP A BIT.
LET'S SHOW CHUCK WHO IS BOSS.
YEAH.
LIKE YOU SAID, THE iPAD, I LOVE
THE iPAD.
IT'S NOT GOING ANYWHERE.
THIS IS THE HANDY DANDY iPAD.
THIS IS HOW YOU GET THE HOODIES.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS GIVING AWAY
HOODIES.
I SEE P. BOSS 21 SAYING LET'S
GO.
A LOT OF FIRE EMOJIS.
EXCITED FOR THE SHOW.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
DEET GEEK IS BACK.
SHOUT OUT DEET GEEK.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE TODAY.
THAT'S IT FOR THE COMMENTS.
>> WE'LL GET THEM WARMED UP.
WE HAVE A BUNCH OF GREAT
BASKETBALL GAMES TO GET TO
TONIGHT.
WE'RE ALSO GOING HEAD TO HEAD
WITH CHARLES BARKLEY AGAIN THIS
EVENING.
AS YOU KNOW, CHARLES IS FAMOUS
FOR HIS GUARANTEES.
HE'S ISSUED HIS BIGGEST ONE OF
THE PLAYOFFS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I LOVE GIANNIS' MOVEMENT
WITHOUT THE BALL.
THEY'RE NOT JUST GIVING HIM THE
BALL AT THE TOP OF THE KEY.
THEY'LL SWEEP THE MIAMI HEAT.
>> DOES THAT NEED TO GO ON THE
WALL?
>> HIT THE BUTTON.
I DARE YOU.
HIT THE BUTTON!
THE BUTTON IS RIGHT THERE!
>> YEAH!
>> THERE IT IS.
>> YOU'RE WRONG.
>> SWEEP THE HEAT.
>> A BOLD PROCLAMATION.
YOU KNOW HOW THESE THINGS GO.
WHEN CHARLES BARKLEY GUARANTEES
ANYTHING, ABSOLUTELY HAMMERS THE
BUTTON.
I THINK HE GUARANTEED CHARLOTTE
WOULD WIN AND I THINK INDIANA AS
WELL.
THE PLAYOFFS HAVE -- IT'S LIKE
GAME THREE OF THE PLAYOFFS.
HE'S ALREADY 0-2.
WE ASKED YOU, WILL MILWAUKEE
SWEEP MIAMI MEET?
GAME THREE TONIGHT.
THE LAST TIME THE HEAT WERE
SWEPT WAS 2007 TO THE BULLS.
BEN GORDON AND LUOL DANG AND
THEM BOYS.
AMERICA IS VOTING 59% YES.
MILWAUKEE WILL COMPLETE THE
SWEEP.
>> WOW.
>> YEAH.
>> THERE'S A LOT OUT THERE.
THIS WEEK IS SPECIAL.
FANDUEL IS OFFERING A BARKLEY
SUPER BOOST.
IF YOU AGREE WITH CHUCK THAT
MILWAUKEE WILL COMPLETE THE
SWEEP, THEY'RE BOOSTING THE ODDS
FROM PLUS 200 TO PLUS 350.
IT'S THE BARKLEY SUPER BOOST.
THAT'S DOPE.
FREE MONEY FROM FANDUEL.
WE APPRECIATE YOU AND ALWAYS
SALUTE YOU.
G. MONEY, HAVE YOU ORDERED ANY
OF JIMMY BUTLER'S BIG FACE
COFFEE?
MIAMI NEEDS A BOOST.
I'M SURE SOME OF THE PEOPLE IN
THE COMMENT SECTION ALSO NEED A
BOOST.
AS WELL AS YOURSELF.
>> CABBIE, FRESH OFF A WIN --
FRESH OFF A PARLAY WIN.
THAT BEING SAID, CABBIE, I'VE
NOT ORDERED ANY OF BUTLER'S
COFFEE.
IF YOU WANT TO SEND THE ORDER MY
WAY, THANK YOU, BROTHER.
LET ME ASK THE AUDIENCE.
DO YOU THINK MILWAUKEE IS GOING
TO SWEEP MIAMI?
GET IN THE COMMENTS, LET ME
KNOW.
IF YOU THINK SO, I NEED BROOM
EMOJIS TO FILL THE COMMENTS
SECTION.
IF YOU DON'T, GET CREATIVE AND
TELL ME NO.
ERIN, WHAT IS YOUR TAKE?
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE?
HOW DO YOU THINK THIS SERIES
WILL TURN OUT?
>> SINCE LAST GAME HAS LOOKS
POSSIBLE, BUT THE BUCKS HAD
THOSE TWO GAMES AT HOME, THAT
WAS AN ADVANTAGE.
THEY LOOK OUT FOR REVENGE NOW.
IF MIAMI WAS GOING TO TAKE ONE
GAME, IT WOULD BE THIS GAME IN
PARTICULAR, I BELIEVE, JUST
BECAUSE IF TEAMS GO 0-3 IN TERMS
OF A SERIES, THEY'LL BE
ELIMINATED 100% OF THE TIME EVEN
IF THEY GET TO A GAME SEVEN.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT GAME.
IN TERMS OF THE BUCKS SWEEPING,
GREAT ODDS, BUT I DON'T LIKE IT.
I HAVE BUCKED PLUS 170 ON THE
FANDUEL SPORTS BOOK.
>> JIMMY BUTLER HAS NEVER BEEN
SWEPT IN HIS CAREER.
I'M SURE HE DOESN'T PLAN ON
STARTING A TREND THIS SERIES.
THE MIAMI HEAT SHOT 50
THREE-POINTERS IN GAME ONE AND
THEY FORCED OVERTIME.
I WOULD SAY THEY REOPEN THAT
PLAYBOOK.
GO BACK TO VOLUME SHOOTING.
IT WORKED FOR YOU TWO GAMES AGO.
YOU'RE BACK ON SOUTH BEACH,
YOU'RE IN THE CONFINES OF YOUR
BED AND YOUR HOME GYM.
LIGHT IT UP.
SO, I -- LISTEN, MIAMI -- EXCUSE
ME, MILWAUKEE HAS MORE TALENT,
THEY WILL LIKELY WIN THE SERIES.
I'M PREDICTING 4-1 AT 170, LIKE
YOU, ERIN.
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO
BE A SWEEP.
THE HEAT WILL GET 1 OR 2 ON
SOUTH BEACH.
IF IT'S NOT TONIGHT IN GAME
THREE, IT WILL BE IN GAME FOUR M
JUST LIKE LAST YEAR, WHEN MIAMI
WAS UP 3-0, THE BUCKS WON THAT
FOURTH GAME.
THEY HAD A SWEEP OUT OF THE
BUBBLE.
I DON'T THINK THE BUCKS WILL
SWEEP THE HEAT.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON THIS
PARTICULAR SERIES?
DOES ANYBODY AGREE WITH CHUCK
THAT WE'LL SEE A SWEEP IN THIS
SERIES?
>> CABBIE, TO BE HONEST, I'M
SEEING A LOT OF SWEEPS IN THE
COMMENTS.
>> YEAH?
>> SEEING A LOT OF SWEEPS.
I SEE JESSE BOLANOS, YES, THEY
WILL SWEEP.
GIANNIS IS ON A MISSION.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, JESSE.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOO
HOODIE.
HOLD ON, DODO BIRD 1 SAYS BUCKS.
BUCKS IN SIX.
JIMMY GOT SOME BUCKETS IN HIM.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU DODO BIRD.
>> OUTSTANDING.
>> HERE WE GO.
HOLD ON.
RYAN RAY SAYS SWEEP, CABBIE.
RYAN RAY SAYS SWEEP.
SHOUT OUT TO EVERYBODY I JUST
NAMED.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
HOODIE.
MY TAKE, CABBIE, I THINK IT'S
GOING TO GO SIX.
NO SWEEP.
I THINK IT WILL GO SIX.
MIAMI HAS A TEAM FULL OF DOGS.
I SAID IT LAST YEAR.
>> DOWN 0-2.
THEY JUST GOT BEAT BY 4,000
POINTS.
>> WHOA.
WHOA, CABBIE.
>> COME ON, MAN.
THEY GOT DOGS, BUT THEY GOT
MOPPED LAST GAME.
>> YOU'RE NOT LYING.
YOU'RE SPITTING STRAIGHT FACTS.
THEY'RE STILL SOME DOGS.
>> HE HAS SOME STUFF LEFT IN THE
TANK ESPECIALLY JIMMY BUCKETS.
>> MY GUY SAID HE HAS SOME
BUCKETS LEFT IN HIM.
BAM HAS SOME BUCKETS LEFT IN
HIM.
DUNCAN ROBINSON, KENDRICK --
THEY HAVE BUCKETS LEFT.
THAT BEING SAID, I THINK THEY
CAN WIN TWO.
THEY CAN WIN TWO.
THIS SERIES IS GOING SIX.
THAT'S WHAT I WAS TRYING TO SAY.
>> SALUTE TO DODO BIRD.
LIKE, DODO BIRD IS EXTENT LIKE
GREG IVORY'S WINNING TICKETS.
CHECK OUT THE NBA PREGAME SHOW
ON TNT FOR CHARLES BARKLEY'S
PICKS.
IF YOU'RE RIDING WITH HIM, GET
ON FANDUEL AND BET THE BARKLEY
BOOST.
IT'S OUR FAVORITE BET OF THE
YEAR.
JUST IN BETTING PERIOD.
THE 3 BY 2.
WILL THERE BE TWO THREE-POINTERS
MADE IN THE FIRST THREE MINUTES?
WE'RE ASKING FOR EITHER GAME
TONIGHT.
MILWAUKEE IN MIAMI OR PHOENIX IN
LOS ANGELES.
WILL THERE BE -- WILL THE THREE
BY TWO HIT IN EITHER GAME?
LAST WEEK BOTH THREE BY TWOS
HIT, ONE SQUEAKED OUT AT THE
LAST SECOND.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SEE IF THEY'LL HAVE A CHANCE
TO WIN.
>> MALCOLM IS NOT AS SLOW MOTION
AS KYLE ANDERSON BUT JUST SO
CALM WITH IT.
SALUTE TO YOU, P.J. WASHINGTON
FROM THE CORNER, MONEY.
THE ONLY HIT.
EVAN FOURNIER WEARS A DEFENSIVE
END'S NUMBER.
>> SPARK.
YES.
>> OH.
THAT WAS SO CLOSE.
HE SAW THE BALL ENTER THE
CYLINDER AT THE NINE-MINUTE MARK
AND FANDUEL GRANTED THAT A WIN.
SALUTE TO EVERYBODY AT FANDUEL.
THANK YOU, MARCUS SMART, FOR
CASHING THAT THREE BY TWO.
G. MONEY, WHICH MATCH-UP DO YOU
AND THE WINNERS ONLY ARMY LIKE
TONIGHT?
>> CABBIE, LET ME TALK TO THEM
REALLY QUICK.
GUYS, GET IN THE COMMENTS, LET
ME KNOW.
LET ME KNOW.
TALK TO ME THROUGH THE COMMENTS.
WHICH THREE BY TWO SHOULD WE
RIDE?
ROCK WITH MILWAUKEE AND MIAMI,
PHOENIX/L.A.
YOU GUYS LET ME KNOW.
ERIN, WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING?
ARE YOU LEANING TOWARDS SOUTH
BEACH OR ARE YOU LIKING THOSE
VIBES IN L.A.?
>> DEFINITELY LEANING TOWARDS
SOUTH BEACH.
THE BUCKS MADE THE MOST THREES
IN FRANCHISE HISTORY LAST GAME
GOING 15 FROM 29 FROM
THREE-POINT LINE.
THEY'RE LIGHTING IT UP.
I KNOW MIAMI WAS NOT GREAT
SHOOTING 29% FROM THE
THREE-POINT LINE.
THEY'LL HAVE TO START OFF QUICK
TO MAKE SURE THE BUCKS DON'T
JUMP OUT TO THAT LEAD.
I'LL GO WITH THE HEAT GAME.
>> I LIKE THE SECOND GAME IN THE
DOUBLEHEADER IN THE STAPLES
CENTER TONIGHT.
I SUBSCRIBE ETO THE NEXT MAN UP
THEORY, SINCE CHRIS PAUL IS
BATTLING A SHOULDER INJURY,
WE'RE NOT EVEN SURE HE CAN GET
HIS ARM TO 90 DEGREES.
THE NEXT MAN UP IS CAMERON
PAYNE.
3 FOR 7 FROM DOWNTOWN LAST GAME.
BECAUSE PHOENIX IS THE RARE TWO
SEED BUT THE UNDERDOG IN THE
SERIES, THEY HAVE TO PLAY WITH
URGENCY.
THE PRESSURE IS ON L.A., NOT
PHOENIX.
THESE GUYS CAN GO OUT AND SHOOT
WITH EASE.
DEVON BOOKER, BRIDGES, THAT'S
PAYNE.
GIVE ME THE THREE BY TWO.
I'M NOT SAYING IT'S ONLY THE
SUN
SUNS HITTING SOME THREE-POINTERS
IN THE FIRST THREE MINUTES.
POPE MIGHT GET ONE IN, MIGHT
SHOOT ONE FOR THE LAKERS ON THE
OTHER SIDE BECAUSE LeBRON WAS IN
HIS GRILL LIKE YOUR BOY DRAYMOND
GREEN IN KEVIN DURANT'S GRILL
AND URGING HIM TO SHOOT BECAUSE
HE HAS SO MUCH CONFIDENCE IN
HIM.
THREE BY TWO, SUNS/LAKERS.
THAT WILL HIT.
G. MONEY, WHICH GAME DO YOU LIKE
TONIGHT FOR THE THREE BY TWO?
WHICH GAME DOES THE ARMY IN THE
COMMENTS SECTION LIKE TO LOCK IN
THIS EVENING?
>> CABBIE, ERIN, I'M SEEING A
LOT OF -- I'M SEEING BOTH GAMES,
ACTUALLY.
>> OKAY.
>> I GOT HEAT/BUCKS.
PHOENIX/LAKERS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, NASH.
WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
>> STEVE NASH?
DOESN'T STEVE NASH HAVE A GAME
TONIGHT?
>> IT MIGHT BE STEVE NASH.
I DON'T KNOW.
ERIN TRISTAIN, PHOENIX.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I SEE DEET GEEK IN HERE TALKING
ABOUT THE MIAMI/WALK GAME.
>> WHICH GAME DO YOU WANT TO
LOCK IN?
>> CABBIE, I'M GIVING THE PEOPLE
HOODIES HERE.
>> MY BAD.
MY BAD.
>> JAKE -- JAKE LESTON,
PHOENIX/L.A.
SORRY, HERE WE GO.
I'LL GIVE YOU WHAT I'M THINKING.
I'M GOING TO -- LAST WEEK I
THREW THE VIBES OUT THERE.
THREW THE VIBES THAT BOTH THREE
BY TWOS WOULD HIT.
GUESS WHAT?
THEY BOTH HIT.
WE HAD A LITTLE CONTROVERSY AT
THE END.
A LITTLE CONTROVERSY AT THE END.
WHETHER IT WENT IN AT 9 MINES,
8:59.
>> 9 MINUTES.
>> THE VIBES -- THE VIBES PUSHED
US THROUGH.
PUSHED US THROUGH WITH A
VICTORY.
I'M SAYING BOTH OF THE GAMES.
LOOK AT BOTH OF THESE GAMES.
TAKE THE YES ON BOTH GAMES.
IF I HAD TO CHOOSE ONE, IF I HAD
TO CHOOSE ONE, MILWAUKEE/MIAMI.
THERE'S A LOT OF SHOOTERS ON THE
COURT.
THERE'S A LOT OF SHOOTERS.
DUNCAN ROBINSON.
MIAMI, THEY ALWAYS RUN THIS PLAY
EARLY.
THEY TRY TO GET DUNCAN ROBINSON
OPEN EARLY.
THEY LIKE TO LET IT GO EARLY.
I'M ROCKING WITH THEM.
I'M ROCKING WITH MIAMI.
I'M ROCKING WITH MILWAUKEE.
THEY ALSO HAVE SHOOTERS.
GIVE ME THAT GAME.
IF I NEEDED TO TAKE ONE.
BUT I'M TAKING BOTH.
>> ALL RIGHT.
TAKE BOTH GAMES IN THE THREE BY
TWO.
MAKE SURE YOU CHECK OUT B/R
BETTING'S LINK TO MAKE THAT BET.
TONIGHT IS THE FIRST GAME IN THE
STAPLES CENTER FOR THE LAKERS
SINCE 2013.
YOU KNOW THE PLACE WILL BE ON
FIRE.
CAPACITY ABOUT 7,000, 7,500.
NOT A FULL STADIUM.
BUT IT WILL BE ROCKING.
PHOENIX FACES THE LAKERS IN GAME
THREE.
THIS IS THE 13th TIME THAT THESE
TEAMS HAVE MET IN THE PLAYOFFS.
WE WANT TO KNOW, WILL KING JAMES
REGISTER A TRIPLE-DOUBLE
TONIGHT?
G. MONEY, THE STAPLES CENTER.
IT WILL BE LIT.
IS LAKERS NATION IN THE
COMMENTS?
WHICH WAY ARE THEY BETTING?
BRON TO GET A TRIPLE TROUBLE OR
NOT?
>> LAKERS NATION, ARE Y'ALL IN
THE COMMENTS?
HEY, Y'ALL TELL ME.
LET ME KNOW, IF YOU THINK LeBRON
WILL GET A TRIPLE-DOUBLE, I NEED
TO SEE LeBRON GIFS IN THE
COMMENTS.
YOU LET ME KNOW.
ERIN, IT'S YOUR TIME TO SHINE.
I WANT TO KNOW, STRAIGHT FROM
YOU, YOURSELF, IS LeBRON JAMES
RECORDING A TRIPLE-DOUBLE
TONIGHT OR NOT?
>> I DON'T THINK HE WILL.
HE'S AVERAGING 21 POINTS, 6
REBOUNDS, 10 ASSISTS IN THE LAST
TWO GAMES AGAINST THE SUNS.
HE'S ONLY HIT FIVE
TRIPLE-DOUBLES THIS SEASON.
I GET HE'LL BE IN THE STAPLED
CENTER AND AMPED UP.
IT'S GREAT ODDS, BUT I FEEL LIKE
THERE MIGHT BE A REASON THEY'RE
SO HIGH.
I'M NOT GOING TO TAKE HIM TO
HAVE A TRIPLE-DOUBLE TONIGHT.
>> LISTEN, HE'S BACK ON HIS HOME
COURT WHICH WILL BE WILD.
THE LAST TIME HE DID PLAY AT THE
STAPLES CENTER, HE DID GET A
TRIPLE-DOUBLE AGAINST GOLDEN
STATE IN THAT PLAY-IN GAME.
THE STAKES WERE DIDN'T.
THERE'S NOT THE SAME URGENCY
TONIGHT.
PHOENIX HAS A MUCH BETTER
DEFENSE THAN G. MONEY'S GOLDEN
STATE WARRIORS.
I'M SAYING NO FOR A
TRIPLE-DOUBLE TONIGHT FOR KING
JAMES.
G. MONEY, WHICH WAY IS THE
AUDIENCE LEANING?
>> CABBIE, I'M SEEING A LOT OF
NOS.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S -- I'LL
CALL HIM ANT.
HE'S IN THE COMMENT REPEATING
HIS COMMENTS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, ANT.
I SEE A LOT OF NOS.
I SEE SOME YESES.
HERE WE GO.
JAKE LESTON, YOU ALREADY HAVE
ONE.
YOU WALK AWAY WITH ANOTHER.
R. MOORE, SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
ROCKING WITH LeBRON TO SCORE A
TRIPLE-DOUBLE TONIGHT.
MOTIVATED.
HE'S ALSO ROCKING WITH BROM TO
RECORD A TRIPLE-DOUBLE TONIGHT.
CABBIE, I DON'T THINK HE IS.
I DON'T THINK LeBRON WILL GET A
TRIPLE-DOUBLE TONIGHT.
I DON'T THINK LeBRON IS 100%, TO
BE HONEST.
HE DID BALL LAST GAME, I'LL GIVE
HIM THAT, BUT I THINK THAT ANKLE
IS 85%.
I DON'T THINK IT'S FULL 100%.
I WILL SAY NO TO LeBRON GETTING
A TRIPLE-DOUBLE TONIGHT.
I DO THINK THE LAKERS WILL BALL.
I DO THINK LeBRON WILL BALL.
TRIPLE-DOUBLE, I DON'T THINK SO.
>> IT'S BEEN NICE TO SEE HIM AND
ANTHONY DAVIS HAVE A LOT OF
CHEMISTRY AND COHESION LIKE THEY
DID IN GAME TWO.
IF YOU GUYS WANT TO BET ON THE
TRIPLE-DOUBLE, THAT OPTION IS
AVAILABLE TO YOU AT PLUS 600.
VERY JUICY ODDS.
WE LOVE OUR SAME-GAME PARLAY
AROUND HERE.
THIS WEEK FANDUEL IS HOOKING IT
UP.
ALL CUSTOMERS GET A RISK-FREE
$10 SAME-GAME PARLAY BET DURING
ROUNDS ONE AND TWO OF THE NBA
PLAYOFFS.
TO MAKE SURE YOU GUYS GET THE
BEST BETTING ADVICE POSSIBLE,
WE'VE GONE AHEAD AND BENCHED
GREG IVORY.
WE NEED TO REVIEW HIS TICKET
FROM LAST WEEK.
>> I'M A MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
I'M A MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
>> YOU'RE HITTING THE BACKBOARD
EVERY TIME.
>> THESE BETS WERE GIVEN TO ME.
I WAS TRYING TO RELAY THE
MESSAGE.
>> COME ON, MAN!
>> THAT'S TOUGH, GREG.
>> OKAY.
>> HEY.
HEY.
IT'S OKAY.
I MEAN --
>> WE WERE SO CONFIDENT IN THIS,
TOO.
>> WE WERE.
>> I LIKED THE JAYSON TATUM
UNDER.
>> WE WERE.
I FEEL BAD M I WON'T LIE.
I NEED TO BE ON PUNISHMENT.
>> YES.
ABSOLUTELY.
I WILL SIT DOWN, TAKE SOME TIME
TO RECOLLECT MYSELF.
HAND THE BATON OFF TO ERIN.
>> I'LL TRY TO STEP UP AND GIVE
YOU GUYS A GOOD SAME-GAME
PARLAY.
>> LET'S HAVE THE EXPERT SPEAK
FACTS AND SPEAK A TICKET INTO
FRUITION.
INTO EXISTENCE.
A WINNING TICKET.
WHAT HAVE YOU GOT?
>> THE UNDERDOG PARLAY HERE.
AS GOOD OF ODDS AS I COULD GET
YOU WHILE ALSO MAKING SURE I
THINK PLAYERS COULD HIT THIS.
THE HEAT MONEY LINE.
I THINK THEY WILL WIN THIS GAME.
IF THEY'RE GOING TO WIN ANY
GAME, IT'S GOING TO BE IN SOUTH
BEACH.
THE BUCKS, SOMETIMES THEY GET SO
EXCITED WHEN THEY GET A HUGE WIN
THEY HAVE A NEGATIVE REGRESSION
THERE.
DANTE TO SCORE EIGHT PLUS
REBOUNDS, PLUS 2 20.
ALSO, DANTE, OVER 3 1/2 ASSISTS,
PLUS 130.
HE'S AVERAGING OVER THIS NUMBER
THE LAST TWO GAMES.
THAT'S TWO GREAT ONES IN TERMS
OF GETTING JUICY ODDS.
DUNCAN ROBINSON TO GET 20
POINTS.
LET'S LOOK AT THOSE ODDS.
I TRIED TO GIVE YOU AS BIG AS A
PARLAY I COULD GIVE YOU.
>> THOSE ARE LEGIT.
YOU ARE AN OPTIMIST.
>> WE'RE GOING FOR LONG SHOTS
HERE.
BUT WE NEED TO.
>> DANTE, EIGHT REBOUNDS WHEN
GIANNIS IS OUT THERE ROAMING
AROUND AND BAM ADEBAYO IS
ROAMING AROUND?
THAT'S OPTIMISTIC.
>> GOING FOR IT.
>> DUNCAN ROBINSON, 15 POINTS?
THAT DUDE HAS TO HIT AT LEAST
FOUR TRIPLES.
>> WE'LL SEE.
DOWN IN SOUTH BEACH?
>> THAT'S WHAT HE DOES.
THAT'S WHAT HE DOES.
>> I WISH YOU LUCK.
GREG, WHAT DOES THE AUDIENCE
THINK OF THIS TICKET?
>> THEY'RE PROBABLY RIPPING ME.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, THE AUDIENCE IS SHOWING
ERIN LOVE.
SHOWING ERIN LOVE.
SHOUT OUT TO FRANK.
YEAH.
SHOWING ERIN LOVE.
THEY THINK -- I'M GOING TO SPEAK
FOR THEM.
I WILL SPEAK FOR THE PEOPLE.
I WILL SPEAK VIBES FOR THIS
PARLAY.
I HOPE IT HITS, ERINMENT SENDING
VIBES FOR YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
NEED THEM.
>> POSITIVE VIBES.
A LOT OF GOOD VIBES.
HOPE YOUR PARLAY HITS.
I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING I DON'T
LIKE ON IT.
THAT'S BEING HONEST.
THE PEOPLE ARE BACKING IT.
THEY LIKE IT.
>> WE HAVE SOME POSITIVE VIBES,
GOOD VIBES.
GOOD LUCK.
THAT'S A LONG SHOT, PLUS 3,000.
>> IT IS.
>> IF IT HITS, THEN YOU HAVE A
VERY NICE -- YOU'LL ENJOY A NICE
WEEKEND IN PHILADELPHIA.
SO, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
TAPPING INTO THE "GROUP CHAT"
LIVE IN THE BLEACHER REPORT APP.
SWING FOR THE FENCES AND
SAME-GAME PARLAYS WITH THOSE
ROLE PLAYERS.
CHECK OUT FANDUEL FOR MORE
INFORMATION, ON HOW TO BET THE
BARKLEY BOOST AND TO BUILD A
RISK-FREE SAME-GAME PARLAY.
LOCK IN YOUR CALENDARS.
WE'RE BACK NEXT THURSDAY FOR
ANOTHER EDITION OF THE "GROUP
CHAT."
ALONGSIDE ERIN DOLAN AND GREG
IVORY, MY NAME IS CABBIE
RICHARDS.
WE'RE LEAVING THE "GROUP CHAT."
HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND.
BE SAFE.
GOOD LUCK, EVERYBODY.
♪